To help you learn new material, we created a unique
concept map for each lesson. Here's an incomplete map for lesson
1 that you can also download from the instructor's notes.
Print it out or just keep it handy, and see if
you can fill in the empty blanks. As you go
along. At the end of the lesson there will be an
opportunity for you to fill in the missing words to see
a complete version. If you prefer to have the complete version
as you go through the lesson just skip to the end of this lesson and
look in the instructor's notes for the
complete concept map of Lesson One. I highly
encourage you to try using the incomplete
version now though. Filling in your own notes
as the lesson progresses and then checking out
the completed map at the end after finishing.